hey guys what's up welcome to another
video tap tap tap tap tap tap tap I'm
sick which is okay because I wanted to
make this chill video for quite some
time showing off my figurine collection
yes that's right who doesn't want to
know about my mannchild hobby who
doesn't care about toys I know you do
hmm for real uh you may have seen in the
in the back I usually have some
figurines there and I got a lot of
questions about them so now I'm going to
tell you and start off right away with
the ones I typically have the cars
figurines bab el gato got all three of
them maybe Marzia my lovely girlfriend
gave me these for my birthday I'm very
happy with these these are probably one
of my favorite and that's why they just
look so good now cause is an incredible
artist I I've been following his stuff
for a couple years these sort of
figurines would go for like 50 bucks
back in the day and I think now they
these just one range from like $200 to
500 maybe I don't know it's insane how
popular they become they've sort of
became a hypebeast
symbol almost which is really strange I
got this cost tattoo you a couple years
back a one-in of one of his figurines my
favorite one which I actually don't own
it's fine I haven't I have the tattoo I
don't need that and I saw it in the
background of like a DJ collied video
and I just cringe so hard maybe it's
unfair for me to judge DJ Khaled's
opinion on art but I just I think a lot
of people just want these for the not
for the sake of the artist and the
artwork just because they're their
symbol now they sort of become a symbol
of the hypebeast culture we
it's a shame because I think cause the
artist has a really interesting history
he started off as a graffiti artist just
scribbling on top of ads in New York
City super cool stuff but then I think
he got promoted a lot by really big
celebrities like Kanye West and Pharrell
Williams and DJ Khaled and I guess me
now if you want to get one of these I
recommend watching out for fake ones
make sure that the bottom has Medicom
TOI China so it's signed if it's really
cheap it's probably fake I've seen a lot
of these go for like 20 bucks on eBay
it's fake you don't want to get fake
stuff that's not cool I love this one
this so this is the version that has the
intestine exposed and the why I rub that
so essentially it's a the Mickey Mouse
undead version I don't know I don't know
what it is to be honest this is an
amazing piece of art let's put them on
the show I mean come on they look great
they look great next one you probably
haven't seen
it's a figurine custom-made from Japan I
bought it in this store called Amanda
Rocca which is in Tokyo Shibuya they
sell a lot of custom toys and figurines
and vintage toys as well I thought this
was a vintage toy Marty I gave me this
one as well so where Mike's have paid
for half of these my head screws it's it
can move its leg this one is from kikiki
toy they do different versions of these
like different colors different stuff
like that I think they are about 20 300
yen which is like $215 or pounds which
is a bit expensive yes but I always like
to get one of these from on the rocket
when I go to Japan as a memory of that
trip and it's worth it
like I know for some people it might be
outrageous to spend that amount of money
on a figurine but I'm I'm very pleased
with it it's a fine piece of art and I
would never
get rid of it another collectible type
of figurine is this brick bear you've
probably seen these they do a ton of
different variations of these this is
the Mount Fuji version it's very cool is
another thing I bought because I wanted
to get a memory from another Japan trip
I've been five times now and it never
gets dull I know it's kind of a bleep he
just loves Japan but how can you not
it's so much fun every time I go and I
want to get a memory of a figurine so I
got this one this one is probably like
50 bucks 20 bucks some variations of
these I swear like a thousand or five
thousand they're insane I probably
wouldn't get more of these even though
there you can technically collect like a
bunch of different ones it's a bit too
simple for me I don't I don't really see
the mass appeal of these to be honest as
much as I do with the cause this feels
more like a collectible figurine toy
cause as work seems more like artwork to
me at least that's how I see it
and speaking of which another gift from
Marcia I'm paying for a Gary Bassman
porcelain figurine careful not to drop
this extremely detailed extremely
beautiful this is number 224 out of I
think 815 I think this one is like 500
pounds pretty expensive but it's made
together with a porcelain company la la
drew I love this art I love Gary
basements art he's another very
underrated artist I would say compared
to costs
definitely check him out if you want to
get some like cheaper but still really
cool figurines this one is more
expensive because it's a special edition
but I love this one I just realized he
has the eye that actually looks like
that tattoo that I have hey I got
tattoos of my figurines how about that
Gary baseman does just like cause
incredible piece of art and paintings I
mean but then he got into 3d art and I
think that's where he really shines I
think this sort of stuff is just so cool
again this feels more like an art piece
of art then then a figurine or something
like that I don't
next up we have very proud of this one
it's Gundam of Zhu ku
I don't watch Gundam I just loved
building them I don't know if that's a
shameful thing to admit or not but
typically I would say building models so
basically I built this myself just
putting all the pieces together you have
to build the skeleton and then from all
the exterior it took me a couple days at
least it's not very well built because
pieces tend to fall off I'm gonna try to
be careful but like it can go into
rocket mode so we can put all these off
and then this should come off as well
dude does anyone care about this I care
so shut up you can open up the helmet
you can take off the you can take off
the the thing and then move this up and
you got a little dude sitting there and
he can go into his power mode and there
you go look at that I think is like
every single piece of this are just bits
put together so you're not really I
guess unless you glue it you're not
really supposed to fiddle with it
and has so many goddamn moving parts
it's ridiculous I'm not making a great
case for this all right this is the only
piece I broke okay shut up
someone's gonna make a 20 minute video
explaining what I did wrong as a
response
I said I'm proud of this be quiet there
you go look he's fine he's fine
Goku is fine anyway I would love to
build more of these this is a perfect
grade version which means it's one to
sixteen scale if you want to get one I
think this is like 150 bucks but you can
get a smaller version I think like I
said I think building models is kind of
lame but just because they're so well
designed these is so cool it's like you
get a cheaper really cool figurine next
up we have this Godzilla figurine yes
this is actually just a toy for kids
I love Godzilla I mean how can you not
love Godzilla you have a country that
gets that goes through two of the most
horrific bombing of history and then out
comes this metaphorical figure
that is just so badass but what I love
most about this thing is that a lot of
people come over and they look at this
and if you move the legs it does that
and it pokes their eye out
it's hilarious next up is another
figurine for my second trip to Japan
Amanda rakia again it's a custom toy I
love this one I have no idea where it's
from I don't know what its referencing
but Illuminati am i right look at that
I love how asymmetric it is like all the
detail it really feels like it's it's
personally just hand-drawn and made
which i think is really cool obviously
that's not the case that would cost I
think a lot more but I think it also has
some Nazi symbols on it which is a bit
strange in these titties I just realized
but it's probably the Buddhism but for
the sake of ad revenue I'm gonna put
this one away now thank you
remember what I said about the fake
costs you gotta be careful because this
was gifted to me as well this is another
gift and it's fake it has no sign at the
bottom the plastic feels kind of cheap
it's kind of squiggly like you hear that
which is a shame because I love this art
I love this figurine I'm not okay with
art theft I'm very strongly against it
but since it was a gift it can't be
helped it's a shame but I still love it
it's still it's still a nice gift I can
I'm still very happy with it but yeah be
careful if you're buying figurines to
make sure you don't don't get fake ones
my third trip to Japan I got this bad
boy manda rocky as well so cool I
thought this was a vintage toy when I
bought it but it's a it's a custom made
from Japanese symbols I don't know what
they are I love the scarf detail I guess
it's some sort of desert monster it's
like a scorpion or something like that
turning to a I don't know it's very cool
that's all I know it's very cool
come on got another original fake cost
figurine I love the design of this one
this one is real I feel like they
literally was like since these figurines
got so popular he was all just like you
guys would literally buy anything I put
out you know I can I can just mess up
the figurine you guys will literally
still buy it and lo and behold this is
where hundreds of dollars
I'll owe it's still incredibly well
designed for being just a mess and it
stands up fine like it's it's really
cool I really love it even though it's
kind of kind of a statement
I feel like against against the
consumers or its movement I suppose now
from my latest trip in Japan I didn't
pick up any thing from on the rocket I
did buy this blame figurine it's kilee
blame of course he is the best manga of
all time it's a shame the anime wasn't
that great but at least you get some
cool figurines out of it and I'm very
happy to finally own some blame
merchandise or blam I also got the
safeguard which is hilarious if you want
to pose it I don't think this is how
this toy was intended but it's very cool
I didn't particularly like the safeguard
design in there in the anime but the
figurine looks really cool actually I
also got this you probably saw in my
blog it's not a Gundam I'm such an idiot
it was in the Gundam section of the
store so that's why I got confused and
everything is in another language but
it's really cool it's got the little guy
on top which is dope I can open up here
and I think there's a guy in there as
well yeah it is so it is kind of a it's
like a mecha the eyes lit up as well
which is pretty dope very happy with it
nevertheless even though it wasn't what
I wanted I also got this gold and Gundam
which is so cool I built this as soon as
I got home it looks so sick this is like
20 bucks
amazing how cool is that come on I don't
know just a quick show because I
realized I probably have been going on
for quite a while I think the back comes
out
yeah it does I guess this is like his
wings or some so cool drink every time I
say so cool in this video last but not
least better my favourite figurine it's
not a figurine you can probably tell
that it's Gary basemen again I have a
Gary baseman tattoo as well actually I
love his art this is like his his I
configure Toby and he sold this I think
I saw a tweet or something that he's
telling these and I was like I don't
think I bought anything that quickly I
got number 94 out of a hundred I'm so
happy I got one of these it's incredible
I don't know how much this is worth like
I feel like this would be worth a lot at
this point cuz Toby is like his main
figurine this is so cool I usually don't
like plushies and stuff I guess it's not
a plushie but it stands up because of
his tail I love the art it reminds me of
monkey bone if you've seen that movie it
feels like a like a cursed item that you
buy you buy somewhere and then your
whole life gets messed up just like mine
did so dump and that concludes my
figurine collection which one was your
favorite
let me know do you collect figurines as
well let me know I hope I will feel less
sick tomorrow I think I have a little
bit of fever so it kind of makes sense
to do a shield video I hope you enjoyed
it please leave a thumbs up if you do I
would really appreciate it a lot that's
it for me for now have a great one
goodbye